well by the looks of it it will be the
same procedure is every year whenever
there's g20 or the g7 meet somewhere
protest is inevitable globalization
critics come in many shapes and sizes
and they will all show up in force and
protests usually doesn't stay polite for
very long violence unfortunately can be
expected but I'm not talking the studio
by Kristian Ferber who is an author and
activist and a outspoken globalization
critic Kristian do you think protests
like that that in in Hamburg can
actually achieve anything the leaders
are sealed off someplace and what can it
achieve for the last 20 years I haven't
seen a major achievement so we should
have different rights rights to propose
to initiate laws and to change the rules
for the world trade to shift it from the
World Trade Organization
to the United Nations to restrict the
rights of transnational corporations to
ask them to do a common good balance
sheet to do a global fusion control and
the text authority it would be a
different type to shape the
globalization and to make human rights
and labor rights liable and suable
instead of the means of the economy
which are trade and investment
they are just the means and they should
serve the goals and now they are being
turned into goals in themselves and this
is a different type of protectionist
matter actually governments are
producing a protectionism for the sake
of investment and trade can I ask you
free trade it's one of the big issues
that is g27 you want to put the brakes
on free trade why briefly if you can
free trade is already the wrong term
because free trade is that these guys
linguistic disguise for this call
already called protectionism retail
trade what would it mean that we enforce
trade lie ibly and also see ibly
although human rights are violated
although inequality is ever rising
although we hit global climate and
destroyed environment that's not nothing
with freedom that's mercantilism or it's
enforced trade and the alternative would
be ethical trade where trade is just a
means to serve human rights to surf the
climate to surf democracy that's the
alternative we're going to talk about
that a bit later well Christian here is
not the only one who thinks that worlds
must change its rules criticism is
widespread and diverse and it's not a
new issue let's take a look at how trade
rules have evolved over the past decades
and indeed centuries from the Middle
Ages to today's g20 international trade
has come a long way how did free trade
develop in the Middle Ages this was
standard practice merchants paid tolls
at bridges mountain passes and city
gates when they moved goods from one
Principality to the next many came via
the sea they loaded up boats with fish
and preserved them in salt or put brandy
and the wine to stop it going bad clever
moves but they still couldn't find a way
to avoid those pesky tolls the merchants
wanted them abolished and they also
wanted to defend themselves against
pirates and thieves on dangerous trade
routes so they joined forces in northern
Europe they founded that German
Hanseatic League in Lubec in 1280 it was
a great international alliance a
confederation of merchants from large
cities that soon began to grow first
Hamburg then Rostock and cologne cities
much farther away soon set up hands at
trading posts to buy the 14th century
the league included almost 200 cities
the cog is the vessel most closely
associated with this trading network a
lot of goods fit into its voluminous
haul Hanseatic merchants were the global
players of the Age they could speak
foreign languages and were generally
well-educated rich and had great
political influence but the Hanseatic
League never became a proper free-trade
zone
in 1800 much instill had to pay customs
duties in 41 different German states and
free cities but increasingly the idea of
free trade caught on in 1833 the german
customs union created a large tariff
free area over a century later the
foundation for free trade in Europe was
laid the European Coal and Steel
community was the forerunner of the
European
Union which today guarantees free trade
among its member states the motive was
not just economic the idea was to create
a system of shared values after all
increasing trade also plays a role in
promoting peace well back with a
Christian fell by here Christian isn't
that right it isn't free trade one of
the cornerstones of world peace so you
don't kill anyone that you want I think
that's a big myth first there are wars
on resources and there are forced
migration due to free trade people are
killed for free trade so I think it's a
big myth and the interest of trans if
you deal with someone you dude you don't
want to kill someone because you want
him or her to buy stuff for us I am much
in favor of dealing with you nicely
politely and in the just manner that
there are balanced trade balances but
your companies when your workers when
your consumers win and your environment
is not decorated and the same with me
but what governments are doing they're
protecting the most powerful and biggest
too-big-to-fail corporations at the cost
of everybody and everything else and
that's a different game that we are
against you advocate and advocate an
idea you call Earth achill free trade
what does that mean briefly well putting
trade as an end in itself into a means
to serve the actual goals which are
human rights for all of us but suable
human rights you can go before a court
if the corporation is violating your
workers rights just distribution social
cohesion environmental protection which
is fine climate protection and so on and
these trade rules should be made in the
united nations because there are the
other agreements of international law
and a trade rule should be adjusted to
these overarching goals that's the
alternative it sounds like a very lofty
idea how do you know that it actually
would work because if you asked the
sovereign citizens in any country in the
world they would prefer trade rules that
are in coherence with human rights and
climate protection and but they are not
asked and they're not hurt and they only
can protest but they cannot initiate a
different international law which puts
human rights and climate protection
first the first step which would be a
voluntary initiative from the economy
for the common good is the compelled
very comical balance sheet for all
companies that want to access world
markets the better the result the freer
their trade and invest and the worse the
result the more expensive and the more
difficult is the access to world markets
we come back to you a little later thank
you so far the opposite of free trade is
protectionism and it seems to be
enjoying a renascence in many part of
the world in essence it's the economic
variant of nationalism used sparingly it
can protect vulnerable industries from
foreign competition but building walls
could also do more harm than good
what is protectionism protectionists
want to shield their own country from
foreign competition so they establish
barriers the domestic economy receives
preferential treatment it's being
protected protectionists often subsidize
domestic industries in the EU for
example that could be meat or electric
vehicles tariffs are imposed on products
manufactured in foreign countries to
curtail imports that makes foreign
products televisions for example more
expensive and therefore less attractive
to consumers at first it may seem to
work domestic manufacturing gets a boost
more workers are hired and foreign
competitors that produce more cheaply
are edged out by by free trade but the
products produced at home are more
expensive and not always
state-of-the-art since there's no
competition from abroad innovation
begins to lag growth also starts to
stagnate companies produce almost
exclusively for the domestic market
neighboring countries respond by
instituting protectionist measures of
their own and introduce import tariffs
this is what happened after the 1929
stock market crash in the US within just
a few years global trade declined by
two-thirds
once one country Institute's
protectionist measures others follow in
a kind of domino effect over time
protectionist countries tend to develop
self-sufficient economies whether it's
carrots apples or bananas whatever
doesn't grow at home is no longer sold
goods become more scarce and growth
suffers and what about the
protectionists they're left with a
mountain of debt subsidies are expensive
history has shown that a wave of
protectionism is often followed by a
financial crisis and even government
default that's usually followed by
renewed support for free trade and we're
back with Christiane over here
Christiane your economy for the common
good it all sounds very nice but it has
attracted criticism from economists they
say that your model is ideologically
driven rather than economically sound
and dangerously close to Soviet style
command economy what will you say to
that well there is no model that is not
ideological every model behind has a
system of values and indifference to
economists which affirm that their model
is objective which is a lie I make my
values transparent which is human
dignity which is solidarity which is
sustainability which is democracy I
think what hurts them is they don't want
to admit that free trade is the opposite
extreme of protectionism free trade
means that the more trade the better no
matter what the consequences and
protectionism means the less trade the
better which is equally absurd and now I
make transparent an alternative a third
way which has which says trade is a
means and to serve our goals and that's
what they don't like to hear very
briefly though isn't growth as growth be
proven as a major force to drive wealth
in developing economies as well and
growth needs trade one all major trade
nations like United States Great Britain
or Germany or even Japan have been
protectionist in their history that's
what I missed out in
in the in little video and the second is
global growth became ever lower with
progressing free trade so there is no
correlation between more trade and
higher growth it's just not true Kristin
father thank you very much for your
thoughts thank you for